okay go space
will you do the honors
please welcome
jack quinn
hello
hi
hi
casey becker it's so nice to officially
meet you oh my gosh it is so nice to
officially meet you no i can't give any
spoilers away but boy it's exciting to
talk to you
uh
about this movie you are so
incredible in it coming from you that
means a lot thank you so much drew
that's that's insane thank you yeah we
had so much fun making this movie and uh
we're just really excited that it's
getting you know a lot of uh
fans seem to love it you know this is
for the hardcore screen fans and uh
we're just so excited that people
finally get to see it and to be honest
with you i i never thought i would be in
a scream movie ever because when i was
about four years old uh the original
scream had just come out i think i was
trick-or-treating for the very first
time
in my neighborhood and that it was a big
year for ghost space like every other
kid on that block was dressed as
ghostface and i remember seeing this one
kid
with like and i've seen it since it's
like a ghost face mask that's kind of
translucent you can see through it and
you can pump fake blood down it so it
runs down and
when i saw that for the first time i was
like oh no thank you at all i i don't
want to see that ever again and it got
me off of scary movies uh and horror
movies in general for like
years i didn't start watching them until
i was a a teenager and then i finally
you know saw scream and uh it's just so
cool i love that it's a horror movie for
horror fans well i i will say as someone
who knows the the franchise so well
and knows the fans perspective as well
this one does not disappoint and a lot
of it has to do with everybody in it
including you
jack you're so good
now
courtney and uh and nev and david were
just here i've known david literally my
entire life and apparently i'm not the
only one you know did prior to filming i
met david when i was about six years old
uh i don't remember it too well but i
think at one point i like went over to
dinner at his house some somehow and i
remember you know i was like really
really young and i remember like you
know dinner parties you don't really
love that as a kid and i think someone
just showed me to like
david's game room you know he had like
all these video games and cool things
that as a kid i just like i think i
played like super nintendo at his house
when i was like six years old um
it's a david i love how he i don't know
if you saw his documentary he's amazing
documentary you cannot kill david
arquette but um when i saw him again uh
for this i
i i was so excited and i i went up to
him and i'm like it's really hard to
compliment somebody on a documentary
about them i was like you were so good
in your documentary right which isn't
how you
i don't know if that you're not acting
in that that's a it's an odd compliment
to give but uh he was like thanks i
remember you from when you were six
years old in my game room he was uh he
was so nice and he taught us all how to
paint he like
you know he took us on hikes he he's the
nicest person i think i've ever met in
my entire life he really is he is just
he and he is a jack of all trades like
he is
you never know what he's going to do
next whether it's acting and wrestling
or becoming a bob ross certified
instructor he lives
fully which is so beautiful he's the new
bozo the clown now it's it's amazing
like what i don't know what he can't do
there's nothing he can't do
okay wait is it true that you have some
celebrity doppelgangers
yes so um ever since the boys came out
uh many people on twitter let me know
that i look like other uh people who are
in art industry uh and so i get a lot of
i'm gonna run through the list i get a
lot of a lot of rain wilson
uh i get some adam brody i get some on
my good days i i get some joel mchale on
my good days um it's just kind of a
white guy soup that um they've they've
put me in but yeah people are not shy
about telling you exactly who you look
like
all right so
is it true that you have a big celebrity
crush
i did when i was like a very young kid
apparently i kind of barely remember
this but apparently my very first
celebrity crush was vanna white from
wheel of fortune uh
apparently like any time wheel of
fortune was on in our house i would come
like sprinting into the room and go up
to the tv and i don't know if they were
my first words but some of my first
words were were like vanna white like i
was like so
enamored with her for some reason back
then i mean she's amazing of course but
yeah that was uh that was my first we
have a surprise for you by the way oh no
no no no no no no no no hey jack it's
vanna i heard about your childhood crush
and quite honestly i am flattered
even though we haven't met maybe we
could meet one day just to say hello so
until then
god so great to meet her oh my god this
is i mean yeah that was wow uh okay i
got a lot to talk about uh with my
family they're gonna be very uh very
surprised that this happened oh my god
thank you
you made dreams come true today thank
you
well jack i was wondering if i could ask
you a favor all of your fellow scream
mates which by the way why did i not
come up with that before
anyway why haven't i come up with that
before that's amazing hey hashtag
screenmates we just came up with it now
we're the we're the originals we we're
the origin story
for your screen mates um have each taken
their phones and screamed into it will
you do it with us
of course i will all right i got i got
it right here we ready one here we go
two three
okay yours is so cute
that is so cute ready
[Applause]
2022
and guess what
he's my fellow scream mate
[Music]